hey guys how's it going it's just a zoom
and guess who it is
it's me it's wrong I've missed you so
much
I know Justine's been gone in Hawaii and
I missed her terribly
I almost flew in for a day but I
remembered I had made promises an
engagement so it would have been a lot
of fun one night that's insane I would
have flown to Hawaii but like I miss you
very busy very busy and then flow now
and I was like if I can't it's been one
day
yeah that's not worth it but we will go
again yeah not for you today what
something super exciting you guys know
that we absolutely love Starbucks and
coffee and everything that is in that
world of Starbucks love what did you
bring me zombie frappuccinos no bees no
Los Angeles traffic so they may not be
at the caliber oh okay
when I first got them but Ellen are the
phone's gone down a little bit little
whipped cream has deflated a little bit
but I'm seeing a light purple this day
also pretty well
looks like when I picked it up so that's
a good thing this cooler is great I miss
you terribly but you just brought me the
new new this is supposed to look like
brains like zombie brain yeah do you
think so well it's green like you know
the cartoon zombies and then we've got a
little bit of like dark red coming down
so it's kind of like bloody and then I
wonder if this was more foamy because it
did come from traffic so did definitely
deflate a little bit like a No did you
try the Mizpah cotton candy wrapper tuna
I did try the cotton candy Frappuccino
and I tried the unicorn Frappuccino but
I was a little bit late it was the
unicorn one yes it tasted really sour
yeah it tasted like a sour mango I
wasn't the biggest fan of that but I
think this is gonna be a little bit
better house bunch of people I saw cuz I
was reading reviews cuz this is green we
won't know what the flavor was but they
said it should have been like a matcha
tea or something like that makes sense a
green tea a matcha but it's not it's not
miss the mark green apple yeah I think
it is actually a mint and no we're not
meant do you say caramel or caramel
it's supposed to be caramel but I say
caramel okay me too well I'm gonna get
rid of this cooler okay you can get it
on Amazon I got it for a great deal
there you go thank you how to open your
straws like I do this YouTube because I
used to waitress so we used to break
just just the tip like this and then you
would remove the bottom and just put the
top in so that you know people could
remove it themselves that's a good idea
please see soup really like a hip hop
and see if this looks like a nurse
you're really dig in and just whoa just
start carrying Oh Chuck oh is it a red
velvet I don't know
oh is it an apple on the bottom red
velvet on the top what are you is it
freezing whipped cream purple
no taste like anything the color makes
me think it should taste like berries
yeah that's like blackberry raspberries
but I'm not mad and I'm just you know
disappointed what do any other thing
that my mom was Adin what do we do next
not mad just don't know what to do
because right when the unicorn
Frappuccino came out I felt like I was
the last person to try it yeah but now I
feel like I'm trying this right away
okay let's just try it right it's really
sweet
oh this is so weird it's like I think I
definitely taste the chocolate the
aftertaste I was gonna say is cocoa I'm
tasting an aftertaste of cocoa it's like
green apple hits me and I could be
totally wrong it's like a sweet sweet
something we need a sweet Apple and then
the aftertaste is cocoa super sweet
apple and chocolate apples Apple Crunch
there's no crunch there should be Y does
not even Apple at all maybe it's pear
and I can't tell oh oh that tastes like
Apple mm OH maybe caramel apple with a
little bit of chocolate yeah that sounds
good that sounds delicious
that's what it is my vote is a caramel
apple with a little bit of chocolate
aftertaste YUM like whatever this is how
to taste the barrier maybe that's just
I'm getting confused by the Apple the
color is tripping me out because your
color this looks like it should be a
blackberry hmm hmm you haven't give my
drink Cola so I'm gonna get a tummy ache
oh but I think it might be worth it
is there anything hidden in here hmm
look at me let me feel around okay I
definitely finger know there's jumps in
there yeah I probably
like body parts maybe like a problem
bleeding I'm so cool I'd be really
creepy Wow
really creep people out put an eyeball
in there happy Halloween I've got me
what I really really freak people out I
just protein probably I feel like that's
a delicacy somewhere so I would say like
on a scale of one to ten what would you
give this scale one to ten also be kind
of like a scale of like something you
wouldn't obviously have everyday but
just like a yeah probably not everyday
cuz I have my favorite go to Starbucks
drinks cuz I'm really particular I grew
up in Seattle home of Starbucks the
heart of Starbucks so I definitely have
my favorites I would say that this is
pretty neat if you like a green apple
flavor it's a lot of my watch I'm gonna
hit oh no I got I got Hey hello got
whipped cream all over my watch
oh wait did you give it a rating it was
like oh I forgot okay how do we do it
right let me get it right and you maybe
you do a rating first cuz I'm not really
good as Rayleigh I'm not either but I
would say I would give it a 7 but now
this is a scale of 10 so the only reason
I'm giving it a lower score is because
it doesn't have coffee and I love
caffeinated beverages
this doesn't have coffee oh I'm feeling
a lot of energy so it must be from sugar
that's it and I would say the unicorn
frappe because I didn't really like it
was probably a four so just one way
higher I would say it's not my favorite
Starbucks drink in the whole world
but a really neat idea definitely like
this but Starbucks I'm waiting for the
10 where's the spresso shocked I mean I
just drink basic black coffee so I'm
really just a little this is neat I love
it cheers Cheers
mmm
no.2 at Starbucks oh well my cold is
there coffee Frappuccino light I love
that so good however I'm feeling if it's
a really hot day like it has been here
has been like a hundred and 310 degrees
I'll just do an iced coffee with a
little bit of almond milk sometimes a
little bit of coconut milk and then if
it's a hot drink
Oh chai tea latte or a vanilla soy latte
I'm in now do you like the Oprah chai is
it cuz that's a lot of chai it's a lot
of time you like that I always say extra
Oprah and they're like huh that means
extra chai yes see I like just their
regular try but you like try a lot do I
love it well I mean I guess that's it
there's really not much more we could
say about this yeah well I'm just glad I
got to try the zombie Frappuccino got to
try the new new while it's new well guys
thanks for watching make sure you check
out Rose Channel we've done so many
Starbucks videos so I'll also put links
to those cuz they were super fun we did
last year we did the pumpkin and that
was a bad the fall trip all drinks I'm
so great well that's it see you later
bye
[Music]